vincent de dien
vous est ce soir notre tékitoi de la
semaine ce qu'on peut déjà dire c'est
que vous êtes nouveau petit protégé de
laurent ruquier évidemment ça inquiète
beaucoup vos parents
sont morts de peur ça nous inquiète très
tous c'est normal
vincent de diane romont soir
j'ai remis qu'in dans le supplément
l'émission de manabi rabat le dimanche
sur canal nous avait succédé à stéphane
de groot et vous êtes humoristes vous
êtes au petit théâtre hébertot dans un
spectacle intitulé s'il se passe quelque
chose mise en scène par françois rollin
et juliette chaigneau alors on va
commencer par le spectacle qui est
produit par laurent ruquier
le dernier comic produit par laurent et
qui avant vous c'était eric zemmour
il a fait une belle carrière oui mais ça
devrait vous inquiéter quand même
le thème de s'il se passe quelque chose
c'est l'autobiographie et comme vous
avec 27 ans le spectacle dure 15 minutes
comme ça on peut dîner tôt voit un
parcours de comédien classique 1 école
de théâtre il chômage chômage chômage
c'est le mans qui est chiant de chômage
chômage
on avait bien suivi voilà j'ai toujours
gardé et vous êtes lancés dans le seul
en scène comme on dit pour bâtir le one
man show avec un spectacle hybride ni
stand-up ni sketches ont joué beaucoup
avec sa mère alors vous raconter dans ce
spectacle votre démarche vous voir en
vrai
s'il en train de me dire ça c'est le
vrai déclic sabatier où il était
candidat de passe laisse tomber mais je
te jure c'est gagner 5000 bull t'as vu
c'est toujours bien de trois ans pourra
tenter votre l'adoption dans un été
adopté par un couple hétérosexuel et
pourtant vous êtes biais vous avez parlé
à christine boutin de sable l'ordre a
dîné ensemble là il faut leur expliquer
alors le plus dur pour vos parents
adoptifs c'est le fait que vous soyez
gay ou produits par ruquier conduit par
l'udc est d'origine arabe ou comédien
c'est non ça a été un joli melting potes
des trois angoisses ils sont adorables
ils sont adorables huit mois vincent
beaux parents biologiques il devait
dégoûté du
si s'ils regardent ils vont vous écris
pour envoyer un petit courrier en dix
ans mort n'a changé d'avis quand on est
enfin ça fait du bien d'être adopté par
le public non à je m'étais jamais dit la
phrase comme ça ouais ouais ouais
il est aussi adapté par la presse gianni
critique absolument extraordinaire on
regarde
quelqu'un autoportrait je rappelle que
c'est pas interactif
qu'est ce qu'un autoportrait qu'est ce
qu'un autoportrait sinon le spectacle
affirmé d'une solitude débordante
non mais en fait comme j'ai fait une
école de théâtre assez sérieuse où j'ai
appris à jouer les grands textes avec
des gens très sérieux un peu austère
même parfois qu'ils disent
strindberg
et à qui il faut répondre
tchekhov
faire un one man show ce sera bizarre si
ce serait bizarre ce serait un petit peu
comme si un trader surpuissant de la
city gratter un tac au tac pendant sa
pause déjeuner
alors ce petit hébertot à paris voire
très très bonnes critiques effectivement
les gens remarquent la la finesse qui a
quand même hein c'est pas du viva las et
non non non je n'aime pas ça comme
spectateur j'aime pas quand on quand je
sens le type sur scène qui est préoccupé
par le fait que ce soit drôle toutes les
3 secondes moi si c'est pas drôle
pendant pendant une minute si la phrase
me plaît quand même si ces singuliers si
c'est intéressant
il ya ça qui est aussi la télé le
supplément vous succéder à stéphane de
groodt qui est partie pourquoi vraiment
de reçus à faire un procès à titre
posthume
en
fait chaque semaine la bio interdite
d'un invité
avec attali c'était chaud vous avez dit
qui ressemble à un hibou est il là il
l'a mal pris il a prévu dans son
excellent ça lui faisait de la peine et
ça monte ça ma fille j'ai alors eva joly
vous dites je trouve que vous ressemblez
à une prof d'allemand enfin une prof
d'allemand qui cherche vraiment à faire
régner un peu d'ordre dans sa classe de
4e mais alors qu'elle est à deux ans de
la retraite mais c'est tellement juste
estrosi le petit garçon à roulettes qui
faisait vous mme blum en écoutant les
forbans a laissé la place au corps les
hommes de la région paca est alors je
termine avec un âge as tu c'est très
sympa avec najat un bas c'était la
première émission c'était mon baptême ac
les deux jumeaux vous lui dites qui
respectent scrupuleusement la parité
puisque l'un est un garçon fille et
l'autre une fille garçon
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux